after nurses voted to go on strike for
the first time ever
[Music]
midwives say they too face a crisis
during protests across the country they
warned mothers and babies are at risk a
lot of women are very frightened now
midwives are fearful because they're now
recognizing the enormity of the problem
going on for the surveys Benjamin was
born at the hospital in Birmingham where
his mother works as a midwife the care
we got was exceptional but then seeing
the other side and just how horrific it
is for the midwives and knowing that
they're not able to give that care to
everyone all the time it's it's
heartbreaking but she believes it's
obvious why maternity Wards are so
understaffed so coming out of University
with a minimum six to run debt like why
would you do it when you can get the
same amount of money for working in
waitrose and have a really nice life and
you don't have to work 13 hours plus
without having a wee without having
something to eat when you work for
another company the warnings from
midwives come as nursing leaders warn
that unless the government opened
detailed negotiations with them they'll
announce strike days in December
that would come right in the middle of
what's already expected to be a very
difficult winter for the NHS it faces
The Perfect Storm huge waiting lists and
aging population and a recruitment
crisis
latest figures show that the number of
vacant NHS jobs in England has reached a
record high of more than a hundred and
thirty two thousand that means almost
one in ten jobs aren't filled including
more than 46 000 nursing posts pay for
nurses has fallen in real terms over
recent years but despite the struggle to
recruit and retain staff the health
secretary is standing by his claim that
their demands are unreasonable and
unaffordable what they're asking for is
17.6 that would be an extra cost for
nine billion pounds on the NHS budget
but for your viewers it is around three
times more than those in outside the
public sector are receiving and that's
why I think that is unreasonable but the
failure to recruit comes at a cost too I
think we can be more productive but the
problem is that some of the ways in
which we're not productive are a
reflection of that lack of investment so
let me give you a couple of examples we
spend a lot of money on agency staff and
that's a very expensive way of employing
people but that's because we don't have
that Workforce strategy and as winter
looms so does a battle between unions
and the government with staff
increasingly unwilling to keep propping
up the NHS Becky Johnson Sky News
Birmingham